hello I'm Alvin I'm Alvin I'm Alvin
That's Not My Name some of you guys
might have been wondering of the new
status on the making a big season might
be I am excited to announce that it is
going to have a brand new host I'm very
excited to be passing the torch to
someone who is very charismatic
passionate and genuine about Giant Food
and it's going to be bringing a lot of
exciting new energy into the show what's
up everyone my name is Tui and I'm the
new host of this season of making it big
you might have seen me on Tick Tock
making really easy to follow recipes I'm
also an Elevate Chef that hosts pop-ups
all over the country I have dishes that
are inspired by my Vietnamese Heritage
I'm super excited to be taking on this
new challenge and also to be joining the
team here at Tasty this new season is
gonna be epic this is so much flour a
whole lot of chocolate this is so much
dough 16 pounds of meat whole bottle of
best Mayo how big exactly I'm talking
big big baby I'm just gonna measure it
with my heart I'm very impressed with
myself why are you so perfect no going
back now
let's do this I can't wait for you guys
to see what foods I made big for my
friends but for now I'm gonna throw it
back to Alvin I'm gonna be working on
some new exciting other projects but in
the meantime I thought it'd be fun to
look on at the past memories and
highlights we've had from all the
seasons we've done today we are going to
be making giant chicken nuggets and
giant fries the big donut giant
cheeseburger a giant sushi roll giant
spaghetti meatballs giant grilled cheese
it's definitely been an amazing journey
with the show I can't even count how
many diet foods we made just how many
people we've been able to feed and the
excitement that we've been able to bring
to People by making their dreams come
true with giant versions of their
favorite food it's huge it's delicious
it's a work of art it's making it big
it's Freeze Frame freeze oh freeze for
him I'm gonna make a big sausage thing
now Angry octoini
scared yeah it's a lot of rice let me
tell you it's not easy this isn't you
know making it lazy
[Music]
oh man that's looking good
that's a McGriddle slice is bigger than
the whole thing cheers I'm gonna punch
it down
I like punching things
wow that's satisfying we're just making
Giant Food and having a good time do not
handle your newborn like this this is
not how you handle babies don't do this
foreign
I really got them bricks that's a lot of
stuff oh wow that's what we wanted
I'm very excited for you guys to see
what's coming next both for our new host
and maybe checking on seeing what I'm
doing because we're both gonna be doing
some pretty awesome stuff that was fun
so having a hard time letting go that's
okay we all do sometimes thank you for
supporting the show genuinely it means a
lot that you guys have stuck with us
commented like shared or simply just
watched the crazy shenanigans that we
get up to but I hope look forward to see
more
foreign
[Music]